hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from the 2018 speed chess
championship that is currently being
played in chess calm here is a game
between Lebanon Oregon with the white
pieces against the Cara Nakamura and
it's very important to say that so far
in the speed chess championships the
only match Cara Nakamura ever lost was
the one in the first speeches
championship I believe in 2016 where he
lost against Magnus Carlsen in the
finals of the speech Chess Championship
here I have some some graphics here this
is from the chess calm article I will
put a link to it in the description
below so you can check out this and a
lot more content there you can see just
what Nakamura had to do to get here to
play against Levin Aragon first he
defeated Howie fund then he defeated
Maxine Marshall a grub and now he faces
Levin Aragon and on the other side you
can see that there is a clash between
Worsley so and young feast of Duda and
the winner of this match Nakamura Aragon
will face the winner of the match a
young feast of Duda and Wesley so in the
finals of this world chess championship
sorry I'm thinking about rosters
championship because there's a Fabiana
Caruana
and you can see that Levin are also beat
Fabiana caruana all the way on the left
twenty point twenty and half to six and
a half so even here it's well it was a
very obvious that if Caruana wants to do
anything in the world chess championship
against Carlsen it has to be in the
classical time format but that was
already discussed in length would a
further ado let's check out this very
nice game Ireland has the white pieces
and he opens with E for with e5 Knight
f3 knight c6 and Bishop to c4 the
Italian game is on the board Bishop to
c5 we have the Joko piano and here
before a very nice move this is the M
Evans gambit but it was not played in
this game here we have Kings we have
king-size castle this is the main line
of the Joko piano
we have Knight to f6 D 3 D 6 and now c3
what could go for some more symmetry
with knife the c3 but here he takes away
the b4 and
d4 square from the Black Knight and also
in the future he might to decide to go
d4 we have castles by Nakamura Bishop to
g5 pinning the knight h6 Bishop h4 and
now a6 preparing to perhaps expand
further on the Queen side and here we
have Knights - D - mushroom to a7 at
some point if this Knight ever moves you
you might wanna push c5 but also this
Knight ever comes to b3 or somewhere you
don't want your Bishop on c5 to remain a
target so it makes sense the duck it all
the way to a7 and it is a very strong
piece as there aren't really all that
many things you can do to get rid of it
as this light square bishop is now on h4
so it's very unlikely that it will ever
come to e3 but okay
King - h1 with g5 y Nakamura and here
are makes a very interesting decision
and it seems to be the corrected
decision you you definitely want to do
this especially in a blaze game this is
a speechless championship so how you
play the speeches championship first you
play five plus one then you play three
plus one and then in the end you play
bullet not the real bullet but you play
one plus one so this is a game from the
five plus one section and here tonight
captures on g5 so sacrificing a knife
for two points pawn captures Bishop
captures but also for this very nice pin
and if white can somehow get his pieces
into the game it could be very dangerous
with King to g7 Nakamura has the correct
idea he wants to further protect this
Knight but also make room for this rook
to enter the game f4 the king is now on
h1 so the bishop is no longer pinning
the F pawn you do want to open up this F
file we have rook to h8 and here we have
d4
Aragon has to close this file if he went
for pawn captures on e5 which does seem
to make sense
after all you're threatening a bunch of
captures on f6 check and also you will
win the Queen but Hiro Nakamura had the
rook captures on h2 play planned and
after King captures Queen 2hh check came
to g3 you can't go back to g1
because the bishop is still controlling
the G 1 square so you would have to go
to g3 and then Knights to h5 check
your wife would be in a lot of trouble
but if white wanted to white could
actually simply capture here and it
would be a force to draw after Queen
captures rook captures on f7 check now
you can either capture with the Queen
but then why White will just be better
or if you move the King white can simply
keep keep on checking the black king or
here if you decide to capture the bishop
then after Knight to f3 check the black
ink has nowhere to go you have to
capture the Knight captures captures and
now again white will simply be better
yes you do have a bishop and the night
for a night for a rook but the awkward
placement of the black King and the
strong rogue Bishop and the other rook
coming to h1 make White's position much
better so after up to h8 onion did not
go for this F captures an e5 but rather
d4 he closes the bishops control of this
square and now he's definitely planning
to capture here so nakamura capture son
d4e capture son d4 and now without
wasting time Arnon place 'if i've and
okay we have Knight to g4 an excellent
move by by nakamura as now if you accept
the Queen you get rook captures on h2
King g1 and now d3 will discover to
check from the bishop on a7 roadblocks
and Bishop captures King f1 and rook to
H 1 this will be checkmate everything
here was a forced sequence so after
Knight g4 we have h3 attacking the
knight you still don't have time to
capture the Queen and now comes Queen to
g8 here we have nice to e4 by Aragon
nice to e3 attacking the Queen the rook
but also the undefended bishop on c4
Queen to f3 and now Knight captures on
c4 nakamura is happily grabbing all the
material Aragon is throwing at him and
now comes Knight to f6 with an attack on
the Queen and here if you move the Queen
for example Queen to f8 or something
then Queen to g3
and there will be all sorts of
discoveries threatened here like Bishop
to h6 check this would come with a
double check and then Queen g5 will be
checkmate
so Nakamura really has to figure out how
to how to deal with this so he can't go
for this
we're moving the Queen rather he plays
Bishop captures on h3 and it's
definitely the correct idea here our
replace G captures on h3 because now if
you capture the Queen then you get
Bishop to g4 with a discover check from
the rook and after we move the King
Bishop captures on f3 g captures and now
you can simply play d captures on c3 I
discovered to check from the bishop to
the king is now active
King G - now 93 check King moves and now
even see capture some b2 and with
everything hanging the rook is hanging
this rook is saying the knight is
hanging white is just completely dead
here so after Bishop captures on h3 I
mean and decided to recapture who helped
G captures on h3 and now comes Queen to
c8 now threatening as the Queen is also
not guarding the h3 pawn rook captures
and h3 is a threat
we have King to h2 now guarding the h2
h3 pawn and now comes Knight study to
Nakamura simply goes for even more
material attacking both the Queen and
the rook we have Queen to g2 and now
comes Knight captures on f1 just
grabbing more material and you don't
have time for Bishop to h6 check
followed by Queen to g5 checkmate
because the white king is in check you
do have to recapture the night so look
captures on f1 and now you really do
have to be careful if you play something
like this then this checkmate it
definitely is happening King captures
and then Queen to g5 will be checkmate
as the knight is covering the h7 square
so after rook captures on f1 King to f8
starts running away and here
arlynn still has a very nice opportunity
presented to him but he plays f5 which
doesn't work one idea that might have
worked was actually capturing on d6 and
after pawn captures rook to e1 and now
with dis control of the e-file and with
with a lot of ideas like Bishop to h6
again being a threat followed by Queen
to g8 checkmate because the rook will be
forced to capture the bishop here you
would have a lot of chances but if for
example something like 97 taking away
the rooks control of D file so the King
could now perhaps escape but it wouldn't
work
after Knight 2 H
check rope captures Bishop captures here
King would have to escape but now you
would have this Bishop to f6 check King
if the King goes here then you would in
fact have a nice checkmate rogue d7
checking moves and now Queen to Jew it
will be checkmate
but if the King instead after this check
decides to go here then you would have
to again go check King moves capture on
d6 and then figure out how to continue
with this attack came to d8 now Queen
checks here you captured the rook and
now the game goes on it's a very ugly
position but the white should definitely
be better so yeah this is something that
was worth considering but like we said
it's a 5 plus 1 so f5 by Aragon now we
have Knight captures on e5 Knights the
d5 and here comes Queen to d7 Bishop to
e7 check and now ok there's really
nothing to do anymore if you go King to
e8 this doesn't really do all that much
you will still be able to grab the Queen
with a nice fork with Knight to f6 or
you can simply move the bishop attack
the rook and then figure out what you do
from there but either way black will
have to give up the Queen at some point
so here nakamora simply gives it away
now Queen captures on e7 we have Knight
captures and keen captures and here
Aragon has a Queen and the rook for 2
looks a bishop and the night so all in
all black is up material but until he
you know harmonizes his forces it's not
all that clear Queen captures on b7 by
Oregon attacking the c7 point into d7
and now Queen captures on a six now
Oregon tries to grab back more material
as who knows this game might even be
decided by by some loose passed pawn D
captures on c3 Queen the b5 check came
to see it and now be captures on c3 we
have Bishop to b6
now the point is can defending the
bishop bishop is defending the pawn the
rook can now enter the game all of
blacks ideas are now coming into into
motion Queen back to e2 and now comes
Luke to a4 trying to get the rook over
to the Kings side
Queen to g2 and now comes Knight to g4
as the H pawn is pinned you cannot
capture it came to h1 and now comes nice
to e3 nakamura continues in the same
fashion he wants to grab more material
with Queen to c6 and here well you could
capture the knight on f1 you know you're
giving up this rook on a4 so not really
something you want to do here Nakamoto
just wait rook captures on h3 and it was
in this position that 11 iron and
decided to resign the game after he goes
to something like came to g1 then it's a
forced checkmate in 7 but he resigned
before nakamura had the opportunity to
to execute it but if you're interested
well there are a lot of nice discoveries
you can do with a knight but first
capturing on on a2 and then after the
Queen moves Queen e8 check you can just
move the king and after one more check
you can block it the knight is defending
the d5 pawn and after the Queen moves
and now you get Knight captures on f1
King captures and now you simply take
away the Queen there are a lot a lot
more ways you can do this but this is
the fastest one after the King moves is
you do have to play something you
prepare mate and then you simply deliver
checkmate I buy them iron and had enough
after rook captures on h3
he decided he resigned the game so yeah
in the end the result of this speech a
championship match was 17 to 12 in
Hikaru Nakamura's favor so he goes into
the finals and as we've learned Wesley
so has defeated young feast of Duda
so here and the camera will face against
Wesley so in the finals of the speeches
championship I which I believe it is
today or maybe next Sunday I know it's a
Sunday so it might be today might be
next Sunday so should we should be a
very nice clash but yeah so far the only
match Nakamura lost in this event is the
one to Magnus Carlsen in 2016 so and
also interestingly Aragon had a very
nice score against Nakamura in the
longer time formats but in the bullet
our Nakamura is no Nakamura had the
better score in the longer time formats
but here in bullet hour everyone thought
Nakamura would
like crush orange and it was actually
Aaron who won five to four in the bullet
section so now I thought that was also
interesting to mention how about yam
that's the game a lot of fancy play a
lot of Queen offerings and such you know
everything that makes a good chess game
I do hope you enjoyed that and that
you're having an excellent Sunday I
would like to thank Neil on Johnson
Thomas look Mean Girls kutis Dean
shimamoto and Jack o beat for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video so your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content
thank y'all and I'll see you soon